d'assen bonjour dites nous comment est
la situation sur place à tunis
eh bien écoutez nadège y règne un calme
assez inhabituel ici et dans le quartier
de la bourse il faut savoir que
l'ambassade des états unis se trouve
dans un quartier très animé avec des
bureaux et surtout avec la bourse de
tunis
l'ambassade qui seront sur le boulevard
de la bourse juste en face de
l'ambassade d'égypte vers y met et
quadrillée par la police la police
scientifique est déjà sur place
impossible de se rapprocher trop de
l'ambassade
je vois là on va ça que je suis on n'est
pas très loin une explosion comme vous
l'avez dit qui a eu lieu dans les
alentours de 11h15 ce matin sur le
boulevard de la bourse deux individus
circulaient à moto l'un d'eux est
descendu cette moto s'est fait exploser
il est mort sur le coup
le deuxième assaillant est toujours en
fuite il est recherché par les forces de
l'ordre
cinq blessés côté sécurité
c'est le bilan le dernier bilan qui a
été dressé par un communiqué du
ministère de l'intérieur
les écoles américaines qui se trouve à
deux pas de l'ambassade a décidé de
fermer ses portes
par mesure de sécurité pour l'instant
c'est les informations qu'on peut avoir
on a vu les marines déployés tout autour
exploite les marines en en temps normal
à z à l'intérieur de l'ambassade des
états unis et la sécurité de l'ambassade
est assurée par les services de sécurité
de police tunisien qui quadrillent le
périmètre de l'ambassade les likes et
finalement les marines ont été déployés
tout autour de l'ambassade la police
scientifique et sur place des
hélicoptères quadrillaient le périmètre
toujours à la recherche de ce deuxième
assaillant et bien sûr je reviendrai
vers vous dans les prochaines éditions
pour vous donner plus d'informations sur
cette attaque terroriste qui a eu lieu
dans les alentours de 11h15 à la
capitale tunisienne
est ce que vous savez bassem si cette
attaque a été revendiquée ou
pas encore pour le moment il n'y a pas
eu de revendication certaines sources
j'ai pu discuter avec certains
journalistes certains diraient que ce
sera soit un cas isolé ou soit une sorte
de revanche par rapport à ce qui se
passe en libye actuellement c'est des
informations qui circulent pour le
moment rien n'est confirmé pour le
moment en attend encore les communiqués
du ministère de l'intérieur qui tous qui
tombe au fur et à mesure et pour
l'instant tout ce qu'on peut savoir
c'est que ce kamikaze s'est fait
exploser
aucune revendication pour le moment et
bien sûr dès qu'on aura plus
d'informations de la part du ministère
de l'intérieur
on vous tiendra au courant bassem chez
billets en direct de tunis merci pour
ces précisions